if I wore a wire once
around bad guys you know what kind of
audio you're getting
do you piss yourself
why does it smell like [__] in here you
look bad Chris why are you so white I
know you're usually really white but now
you're really really white did you piss
and [__] uh I don't know I must have ate
something dude I would have eaten so
many things in the night guys I must
have ate something sorry I'm just I'm
why are you sweating I'd have to go and
like pretend I was a Target worker
people would keep being like are you
chrysalia and I'd be like no I I don't
know what you're talking about
um I have to go put toilet paper in the
aisles I will be in toy section okay and
that's christalia who said it don't be
blonde smoking on my face you blow smoke
on my face man that's the last face
you're gonna blow smoke in